[Music]
let us
seek a 10 minute game
we're 18 31 so
moving right along
and playing 1868 with white yeah we're
going to go with the d4 we're going to
go more positional
we're going to go more positional
and he goes g6 so this is either a
grunfeld or a king's indian okay knight
c3
okay so this is our first grunfeld i
don't think we faced a grunfeld
with the white pieces
it really is it only becomes i would say
truly popular
at the level of um
at the level of 18 1900
um and
white has a bajillion
options against the krenfeld and they're
all
nothing has been proven to get an
advantage i'll put it this way um and
i'm just trying to think of like a
system that might be easy to play
one system that sort of flies under the
radar a little bit
particularly at this level when people
are often just learning the grunt felt
is to refrain from taking on d5
um
and instead
oh actually i know i know what i know
what to play i know what to play
um we're gonna take we are gonna take
and in the ground field there's a lot of
very off-beat
very off-beat systems that are actually
not that bad and they can give you an
advantage
um if black is not precise
and one of the rarest moves
available in this position this is a
move that
you will not come up with in a million
years and not because you're um
not because you're bad
but just because it's it's pretty crazy
is
knight a4 whoa bandit out of the 10
gifted thank you
damn girl thank you for the 10 gifted
band-a-dad
all right
so
he goes e5 i'm very surprised that he
actually knows this move
and the purpose of knight a4 i'll talk
more about this after the game but the
purp the main purpose is to prevent him
from being able to take my knight in
response to e4 so i want to play e4 and
chase his knight away so it makes sense
from that perspective and in order to do
that you have to move your knight now he
goes e5 this is the main line this is uh
the sacrifices upon and gets an
initiative in return as far as i
remember we're supposed to take this
pawn
and then he gives me like a check on v4
we block with bishop d2 and then i don't
remember the rest
let's see how this goes
um
bishop b4 check we have to cover the
check
yeah knight e3 is a move um
so i'm very surprised that he knows this
line
very surprised uh because this is as far
as i know this is not that well known
now he sacrifices a knight temporarily
but he's going to win the knight back on
a4
he's going to win the knight back on a4
as you guys will see this knight on a4
is going to be undefended after he takes
on d2
and then he's going to go queen h4 queen
takes a four so takes
he has oh and i think he just confused
the move order
i think he just confused the movement
i'm pretty sure
i'm pretty sure that you have to take
the bishop first because here's the
thing
when you take the bishop i have to take
with the queen
then you give a check on h4 and it forks
the king of the knight
but there's a subtle difference here and
that i can play g3
he takes my bishop what's the difference
as far as i know maybe i'm wrong maybe
this is still theory but i don't think
so
we can take with the king and the queen
still defends the knight
so that's the danger of trying to you
know overly parrot a repertoire that you
learned
you confused one little thing in these
very topical openings and immediately
you're losing
uh and our queen defends the knight now
isn't it dangerous that our king is in
the center not really because the king
is going to tuck itself away on c1 so
it's not actually
dangerous that our king is in the center
he doesn't have any pieces out he gives
me a check on b4
some of you might be tempted to cover
this with the knight that would be a
very bad blunder because of queen takes
b2 check
so we've got to be very precise here
and there's no reason as far as i can
tell not to go king c1 tuck the king
away
and then quickly we need to develop our
pieces see that's what some people
uh that's what derails some people in
these positions you start um
you know you start various shenanigans
no shenanigans just got to develop your
pieces consolidate the advantage and
then you're up a piece white has some
difficulty because we've got irish pawns
we don't have the king side developed
we've got some stuff that we need to
solve
um but we'll solve it he doesn't have
his pieces developed either
so yeah move orders are crucial
move orders are absolutely crucial and
when you're studying and opening if
there is a sequence like this you've got
to make sure you're establishing why
the move order is whether the move order
is important and why it's important if
it is
because that will help you avoid these
kinds of mistakes which happen pretty
often
bishop f5 you can play but there's no
threat i mean we just develop our knight
to c3
so it's no it's no issues
it's not weird at all people forget and
confuse stuff all the time
it's it's not 100
totally understandable that he confused
the line grenfell is very theoretical
okay so obviously here we're just going
to f3
okay queen takes e3 check doesn't help
his cause at all we can just block with
our queen
and in a sense
this helps us because now if we move
this pawn out to e4 the bishop will be
open
300 bits thank you so what should we do
now should we go e3 no we should
definitely not go e3 blunders both of
our knights we should instead drop our
knight back to c3 just very simple
now we can move in for the kill so we've
got two
separate ways to win a position like
this we can do it
through the trading method we can go
queen up to d5 and basically force the
queen trade
i don't like that because that's it
seems a little bit
too
i don't know how to define it it just we
don't need to do that because now we
have a lead in development so there's
absolutely no need uh to go out of our
way to uh
to to trade the queens
knight d4 would blunder the rogue so
from that perspective we can fianchetto
our bishop that's a great idea
another great idea is to prepare the
development of the bishop via this
diagonal
and how can we do that yeah we can go e4
and the reason i like this move on top
of
what i just said is that it threatens
the pin it goads him into castling and i
had seen that we have a very strong move
here and the way that you guys should
see this move is to recognize that he
lacks his gruntfield bishop he lacks if
he encounter bishop when you lack a
fiance bishop
these dark scars around the kings around
the king are incredibly weak and there's
a bunch of very thematic ideas that stem
directly from that one of them of course
is to put the queen on h6 and follow it
up with a devastating knight g5 so he
has to push his f on out to stop me from
doing that
in turn that creates other weaknesses
um
that creates other weaknesses which
we're going to so in particular it
creates the weakness of
sorry creates the weakness of this
diagonal so if we put a bishop on c4
that's going to be checkmate
okay so he finds f6 to his credit
and how do we approach the question of
actually finishing this one off
well like i said if we could put a
bishop on c4
that would be devastating
okay so do we go b3 here to prepare it
well that would be
a bad idea because that would blunder
the knight so instead we need to go at
it from the opposite end opposite angle
can we chase the queen away from c6
in order to pave the way for bishop c4
that needs to be done a little bit
carefully um
so how can we do that how can we go
about
doing that
well 95 the night is pinned
the knight is spin guys so you keep
trying to put stuff on d5 and see where
you need to chase the queen away
you need to chase the queen away you can
do that in two different ways i love
knight d4
but i also love the move bishop b5
because this develops the bishop
simultaneously so it's a helpful move
and
we're trying to get the queen off of its
control of c4 that's the bottom line
here but if that doesn't happen then
guess what we could do worse than just
having developed our bishop that's a
good thing
okay queen c5 is a good move so he
continues to stop us from coming bishop
c4
but now
asking ourselves how the position has
changed as a result of the last two
moves
well
now we can we can continue the idea that
we started with queen h6
so um now that we've displaced his queen
from its protection of the f6 pawn
we can
we can continue the idea that we started
now we need to get a knight to g5 that
was the idea
should we do that immediately well no
he's got the pawn on f6 so we take first
we give him the f-file
so if we didn't have knight g5 this
wouldn't have been a good idea there
would there would have been no need to
give him more concessions but we're
going directly for the kill here he's
got to check on e3 it's not dangerous we
can just tuck her king away on b1
um queen back to e7 and now we can
actually move in for the kill
so let's be careful
um what should we do
yeah knight t5 is the simplest you can
come back to c5 with check
but
easily it's easy to see that king b1
defends against all of the checks
and creates insurmountable threats
against this game
so this is mate
this is made and this is winning
yeah this is over
i mean this was a pretty easy game given
that he blotted the piece he helped us
but
but yeah
i guess this guy has the chestable
repertoire though which is good svidler
released the grunfeld repertoire
yeah guys i'll answer the questions
after the game as i always do
more youtube videos are coming out every
day on the speed run i'll just throw
this out there if you
enjoy the speedrun content it really
helps grow my channel if you subscribe
to my youtube
i appreciate each and every sub we're
trying to move to our 200k subs
so it would be a dream if we could uh if
we could hit that
so we had a grunfeld
and the smooth knight a4
is incredibly rare
but nowadays nothing truly is rare
everything's been analyzed everything is
known
and so these kind of like surprising
moves are are actually not
they just don't have the same they don't
have the same effect that they used to a
couple of years ago
uh and knight a4 was first played i
think it's called the nadanyan variation
this is armenian gm who played this
often
he wasn't surprised i mean this guy but
here yeah this has over a thousand games
at this point
nakamura played against nepo
1997 first time it was played
thank you the grand elixir with two subs
appreciate it
and it was no sorry no in 1995 and
ashot nadanyan played it in 96 twice and
beat varja nakobian
and var actually knew var played e5 and
bishop before in 1996. only the second
time this appeared far found this over
the board
and again so what is the point of knight
a4
what is the purpose of this so let's say
black plays normally let's say black
plays bishop g7
white plays e4 and generally in the
grunfeld
black
takes on c3 at this moment so if you
play a main line
okay if you play e4
black takes on c3
and this creates sort of a pawn chain
the black later attacks of the move c5
and that formulates the basis of the
whole
set up behind the grunt felt black
attacks white center
by developing the pieces and channeling
them toward white center
how does knight a4
not allow that like why can't black just
okay so you can drop the b6 what's the
bit what's the big deal here why is this
like supposed to be good for white so
the point is that after so white plays
bishop e3
um that's the main move and this creates
a funny situation
because this knight on a4 which looks
bad is actually stopping black from
going c5
and this makes it harder for black to
assail white's pawn center um
so for instance if black castles y goes
knight f3
and now if black decides to take the
queen on a4 is very very good it's
protecting the deforest upon from the
side
white is already you know as a small
lead in development
and i think the main line goes c5 and
now rook to d1 white gets the pieces out
super quickly and even though black is
able to cut into white's center
uh it's not good enough because white
gets this big lead in development the d
file
is under control
so i think white's supposed to be
slightly better here i i i haven't
reviewed this in a while cd94
i see svidler plays this played this
with black and zhang though thanks for
another gift itself so maybe white is
only slightly better but you guys can
see kind of the point the point is to
disallow knight take c3
okay so e4 knight b6 bishop e3 is the
main line he played e5 which
uh which is the sharp move
immediately exploiting the fact that
white has made a move to the side this
follows the rules you know you meet a
move to the side of the board with a
move in the center
uh e5d five it's very concrete idea this
should be four now knight e3
uh it's it's yeah no 2023 it's a good
surprise weapon still and i think this
is supposed to be equal i don't think
white is worse than this line
and again the whole point is that you
ruin white's pawn structure
now you're supposed to take the bishop
and then fork the king and the knight
with queen h4
g3 queen takes a4 and you get this very
interesting very unbalanced position
where technically white is up a pawn yes
however if you've got irish puns
you've got
sort of a permanently weak king even if
white manages to castle king side
white's got g3 black on the other hand
also has a permanently weakened king
side so both sides kings
are in some trouble i don't know how the
theory goes here i have no idea what
white's main move in this position is i
can check
uh so apparently
white's main move in this position
let me just check one second
yeah so apparently
bishop g2 would be natural fianchettoing
the bishop or knight f3 bishop g225
games castles
yeah knight f3 knight c6 castles
bishop g4 something to this effect
so this is about equal bishop g2
um castles knight f3 knight c6 castles
bishop g4 both sides complete their
development black is probably going to
win back the pawn
i'm checking with megabase yeah
so you know
interesting line svidler apparently
gives us in his repertoire
but queen h4 check is a confusion of the
move order that cost him the game
because g3 if you should be two now of
course king takes d2 and don't assume
that your opponent knows everything if
your opponent is blitzing out the moose
i see a lot of players trusting the
opponent thinking oh my opponent must
have known must know this he must have
reviewed the chessable repertoire
uh everyone you play is human unless
they're cheating and so humans are prone
to confusing openings all the time i
confused
i have many stories of confusing move
orders and confusing
positions in my preparation even in over
the board games against very high rated
grand masters
so you know i can even give you one
story if you think oh it's you know who
is this guy why is he confusing move
order how could that happen
it happens all the time at every level
particularly at the highest level when
you have to memorize just a great deal
of
uh theory just to stay alive
um
so i wouldn't be too critical of people
for forgetting stuff and confusing stuff
you got to hold things in your mind
you got to hold a great deal of things
in your mind
so let me let me see if i can find this
game
this was one of my like
craziest examples of confusing
my prep even though i didn't get
punished for it
so
and i'll have to use stockfish here to
just refresh my memory of like where
what the actual prep was
all right so
so this was a tournament in qatar i've
shown my game with kramnik from that
tournament this is like the strongest
open tournament ever held
and i really wanted to do well i did do
well in both of the times that i played
there
the second time magnus played in that
term i didn't play him but pretty pretty
crazy stuff
um
and so halfway into the tournament i'm
playing chinese grandmaster lee chao
who is 27.50
feed a rating this is three rounds
before the end
and
okay so he he plays the slav pretty
exclusively so i prepared for three
hours i prepared prepare prepared
um
and because he kept playing into this
one line this gambit line where he
accepts upon sacrifice that's supposed
to be bad for black but of course he has
his own analysis and stuff so i stayed
up all night analyzing
i was kind of tired when i came to the
board
um
but still he went exactly to my
preparation
and um
then disaster could have struck
so this is okay i'll show you guys the
whole game
so there was this this was a slav um
this was a slav classical lion now li
chao
goes bishop g6 here and after e4
i mean you can decline the pawn
sacrifice with castles but li chao
always took the pawn and this is
supposed to be extremely dangerous
because after bishop a3
uh i prevent him from castling this is
this sacrifice sacrifices another pawn
but this pawn is basically untouchable
due to queen b2
um as far as i remember and this is a
devastating fork
so
queen c7 uh is is is black's main move
this is theory and so we get this
critical position a6 is the move uh and
all of these moves have reasons behind
them i won't delve into them too deeply
uh the point behind a6 is that black
wants to play c5
in order to sever the connection between
the bishop and the square so black wants
to ensure that he can castle and
castling long is too dangerous because
the open b file
so the reason he plays a6 is to cover
the b5 square because if you go c5
immediately there's bishop b5 with very
unpleasant consequences along the
diagonal
so a6 and
i analyzed this position for a long time
i thought it might happen it did and i
came up with a novelty and the novelty's
h3
and this is some computer stuff
um it's basically a waiting move because
it turns out that
c5 here is inaccurate because white has
the move d5 with a big initiative
um and this is one of the things that i
analyze so in order to
keep a playable position black has to go
knight e to f6 and so drop the knight
back then i go knight e5
then you go c5 and this is the main line
of my preparation knight d7 knight e7
and heroes very proud of myself for
finding this move h4 with the computer
h4
and the point is that if he goes h6 or
h5 to create some look for his bishop
could somebody tell me white's best move
this was my preparation yeah
and i was very i was like man if this
happens i'm going to be really happy
this guy's 27 50.
yeah bishop b6 because the bishop on g6
is now weak
and of course he can't take so he's
supposed to castle here and you get
risk-free position up upon for white
black should probably be able to draw
this but i think you know
you could do worse than having a
risk-free position against the 2750.
um
okay so this all happens but lee chow
goes c5
and in my fatigue
i and anxiety i accidentally i confused
the line of knight ef6 with a line from
c5 and i played knight e5
so i played the move i was supposed to
play only against knight e to f6 and the
moment i released the knight and pressed
the clock
i was like something you know something
feels wrong
when you you can tell something feels
wrong
and i was like wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute
he takes my knight
d takes e5
and he just castles and white is
completely lost i'm down upon i'm about
to lose another one and the knight on e4
cannot be trapped because if you go f3
then the knight swoops into g3 and then
back out to f5
what this is minus 1.5 this position
white can basically resign against
somebody like him
and i was
i mean i was raging so hard on the
inside it was awful
because of how much time i'd spent and
he thought for maybe five ten minutes
until my utter
relief he played knight e to f6 he went
back into the line and so i took and i
played h4
um and i got a big advantage i was
winning and unfortunately i failed to
convert but
incredibly this was a very vivid story
of confusing the prep and getting
incredibly lucky he also probably
confused it
so he probably thought or he thought
that this was some deep prep and he was
afraid to go for the obvious line
but it ended up transposing
um i had another story of confusing the
prime and i have many stories of
confusing prep
oh yeah
well i told you guys the story in the
very same tournament
in the very same tournament two rounds
later sorry
in the very same tournament tomorrow
then the day after this game
i'm playing another 2700 dimitrijako
vancouver who who might beat
um a year or so before that in in the
world team championship so he's got a
chip on his shoulder
i've got a chip on my shoulder i don't
want to lose to him i don't want to lose
him after beating him so the day after
this misfortune happens another crazy
thing happens
um
and i've i've told this story before
so
but it's worth telling again
okay so i play yakovenko
i play yakovenko
and
he's 27 37 i'm black i'm like uh this
guy
this is nasty stuff
so this was a relatively normal game
until crazy stuff happens this is a
catalan
whatever catalan catalan catalan
normal stuff i mean he's got a slight
advantage whatever
i've got a decent position got my knight
to an outpost it's a very complicated
playable position
so he goes rook c2 he trusts double on
c1 i'm like okay
um
so i was worried about rook ac one right
attacking the c6 pawn so i quickly
played
f6 never play f6 i played f6 press the
clock at this point my friend fedesam
came over
he sort of shook hands
um how are you doing you know i'm pretty
satisfied in my position
at this point
but
you know two seconds later i look back
at the board and i'm like wait a second
oh my god i just made a terrible blunder
and it's an even worse feeling than i
had the day before that
because what does white have in this
position this is like a most elementary
tactic of all time how can you play a
move like f6 weaken upon on e6 like this
and then not c
that white has knight takes c6
um
and the game is over because here's how
the line goes now you can take with a
rook it doesn't matter
let's say you take the rook
he takes takes takes e6 forking winning
another pawn and winning the winning
back the bishop
kha queen takes e6 now it seems like
black goes queen d4 and maybe everything
is fine
you're seemingly forking the rook and
the bishop white has the very strong
move rook a2 and
this is actually totally losing
bl white is up upon
a6 is saying white's got the two bishops
black's king is in ruins
this is totally losing
and i mean i wouldn't have resigned but
the game would have would have been a
loss
but
after about two three minutes of
thinking he played knight d3
and the way that i dealt with this is i
actually got up from i got up from the
board um i got up from the board because
i couldn't look at it i felt like he
would read my mind i thought in the slim
chance that he would miss this
uh that chance would be magnified if i
didn't show anything on my face and
pretended that everything was fine and
to my amazement when i came back he
played knight d3
and uh the game went on and i managed to
make a draw so
the game amazingly ended in a draw so i
got
lucky twice this tournament
um and i was thrilled at the way this
tournament ended
the last round i drew for the saf
um
so there's this question how did the 20s
how could a 2700 miss something like
this and
the reality is that you have a very
small sample size he probably sees 49
out of 50 of these tactics this was the
50th
so people think of 2700s as robots
they're very much human
a lot of stuff is missed
oftentimes when you have a blunder this
elementary
2700s are not used to having to punish
such a blunder because these blunders
are not made against them very often
right i don't make blunders like this
almost ever
so they're not in the mode of like oh my
opponent just blundered this super
elementary tactic they're not even
looking for that a lot of the time i
think that has to play a role in it
um
but but this all but this stuff happened
and this is only the tip of the iceberg
no no no there is no way he got scared
of it if he saw this move he would have
played it for sure
he just slipped his mind i mean it just
just fell out of his field of vision
i've never lost my by forfeit no i've
never never not shown up to a game
i think he thought for a couple of
minutes
but probably he was deciding between
knight f3 and knight d3
i honestly think he just didn't it just
didn't occur to him
um and then after the tournament he came
up to me and he was like oh my goodness
like how could i have not seen that
so he definitely missed it he we talked
afterward
and he was incredibly upset during after
the game too because he was he was much
better later on i i drew by the skin of
my teeth
so
he's old how old was he 30 34 30
33 at the time
uh what should i have played
um i mean black is worse
black is worse but uh you know i can
play
maybe like knight b6 knight c4 would be
an idea this is what i played afterward
oh sorry no no not here sorry yeah i
mean even here knight b6 maybe on knight
c4
yeah maybe something like this
trying to intercept
the attack on c6 i don't know
this is seems pretty playable for black
but anyways
um
so that's that
that's that ladies and gentlemen
um
yeah i've never forfeited a game
i've been late a couple of times but i'm
usually not late to chess games
hope you guys enjoyed the story
well there have been plenty of games
with even mismatched one i mean vladimir
kramnik
vladimir kramnik very famously
um very famously blundered made in one
against fritz
and people people's reaction was the
same how could a world champion blunder
maiden
the people who are saying that are not
realizing that
this is one game out of thousands that
this guy has played something crazy is
going to happen
to any human doesn't matter how good he
is at anything
and i think there's a little bit of
idolization that goes on of the top guys
in recent times where people assume that
they're never capable of elementary
mistakes that's not true
very very much capable of elementary
mistakes
also the pressure adds up and stuff yeah
so this was a very famous game and when
this happened this was a huge this went
viral so vladimir kramnik in 2006 was
playing fritz which back then was just
about as good as kramnik they were
playing on equal terms they were drawing
and in this position
this was televised i think although i
don't think there's a tape of this now
anymore
so kramnik
goes queen e3 and he gets up from his
chair
and he walks to get water and the
operator right there was fritz and then
there's the operator who makes the moves
that the computer is indicating
the operator visibly was shocked like he
could he even he saw that there was mate
without fritz's help
and after queen h7 kramnik was
flabbergasted
after the simple king g8 the game should
have ended in a draw
uh this is a dynamically equal position
but kramnik misses made in one just one
of a kind one one out of a million kind
of game
um
so anyways
yeah we're all human that's that's the
takeaway
from that speedrun game no i mean i this
was very famous this is
if if you had seen this you would have
remembered it too
so
no my memory is not particularly
not particularly good this is just this
is a very famous game i can show you a
million examples of like one move
blunders at a high level that i was
witness to myself
uh there was inarchaea against back row
which i was watching i was watching this
game live
um
this was a game between two super gm's
in 2008
uh ernesto
etienne backrow french super gm and
ernesto narcav
uh just both really really strong
players and okay they had a really
interesting game so i was watching the
tournament
as it was going on
and
there was a live feed
there was a live feed
and in this position by crow has
sacrificed an exchange he's worse sir
sellers thank you for the prime
but he's not losing i mean this is
playable
and very famously um well i don't think
this is as well known but crow played
queen e7 check
obviously wondering the queen and he
resigned before black moved i mean he
immediately noticed it
yeah i should do a compilation of both
gambits and among 2700 plus opponents
anyways
um
this is a classical game yeah yeah this
was this was a fide grand prix
this was classical gaming at time it
just happens
so my theory again is the people who
watch this and say how could this have
happened
you know what a disgrace you know 2700
blunders queen oh my god why are they
invited they should never invite him to
another tournament
they're they haven't seen any any other
of that person's games and they just
assume oh
this must happen all the time then it
happens very rarely but
in the grand scheme of things it happens
a lot i mean if you take millions and
millions of games you're gonna have a
lot of them that have one move blunders
this is still
you know on a per capita level this is
almost nothing on a
global basis this is a lot
so anyways
um we'll talk more about that later i
gotta go
i gotta go so thank you everybody this
was a very fun stream the sorry the play
wasn't
was not great today
uh but
the play wasn't great today but uh i i
still had a good time so we'll try to
play better tomorrow i'll be back i will
try to uh
try to maybe do a morning stream
tomorrow
uh we'll see
i don't know if i'll manage i have a 10
a.m lesson tomorrow so
i might stream
from 11 to eastern to two something like
that
and then maybe again in the evening
in the evening
so we'll see
i'll see if i can squeeze squeeze some
good stuff in tomorrow thank you for
hanging out everybody hope you had a
good time i'll do more speed running
more educational stuff tomorrow together
with hopefully better blitz
hope everyone's had a good saturday have
a great rest of your saturday
i'll see you guys later
take care everybody let me see who i can
raid
um i will raid
um
i'll read thirsty monster yeah i'll give
thirsty monster raties rated me
many many times a very talented young
player and streamer
enjoy the stream take care everybody
have a good time see you guys tomorrow
bye
[Music]